easy arancini delicious golden rice
balls
[Music]
first chop mozzarella into small cubes
then take handfuls of leftover risotto
add a cube of mozzarella and fold into a
ball around the cheese
this dish is perfect with leftover
mushroom risotto but it's great with any
risotto
for the coating prep three bowls one
with flour one with breadcrumbs and one
with beaten egg
dip each arentini first into the flour
then the egg wash and finally the
breadcrumbs
then in a pan
heat the olive oil and fry the arancini
until golden brown
[Music]
drain and serve simply with lemon
[Music]
easy arancini a delicious tempting treat
that's great for leftovers and cooks in
under 10 minutes
[Music]
it's wise to save leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine in freezer bags or ice
cube trays it's great in stocks and
sauces
a fantastic tip for leftover lemons and
limes is to cut them into wedges freeze
and use them like ice cubes they won't
water down your drink and they'll also
add flavor
[Music]
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavour left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge
when grinding up spices if you have any
left over you can store in an airtight
jar for up to two months great for a
spicy kick to have at your fingertips
a tip for making the most of spare bread
blitz leftovers into breadcrumbs great
for stuffing or crab cakes or cut into
chunks and freeze for perfect croutons
on demand or simply tear a news in a
delicious rustic salad and when you're
cooking potatoes always cook extra so
there's leftovers they're fantastic to
have on hand for making my delicious
gnocchi and potato rusties for a classic
bubbling squeak always make the most of
your leftovers use last night's rice in
stir fries scrambled up with eggs or
it's simple to make a delicious fresh
salad remember a good cook wastes
nothing
a great tip for using leftover herbs
simply chop finely mix into butter roll
up in clint film and freeze
then when you want a herby hit cut into
slices and melt over steaks chicken or
veg
you never throw out your leftover pastry
it's easily transformed into grapefruit
or savoury party nibbles
roll out
grate parmesan or sprinkle over your
favorite fruit
roll
and then just slice and bake
you